[Applause]
it's all pretend I just created a
character Fallone it Oh
so first things first I I read somewhere
where you said this is one of the most
personal projects of your career how so
personal yeah what did I say that I said
it was one of my most person yes maybe
well cuz you know it's one of my ideas
that kind of developed it from the
beginning and I and Rudy ray Moore it
was kind of like somebody that really
really was a fan of and I thought he had
a really great inspirational story so to
see it all come together you know and
it's not just see my acting and it it's
all this other elements you know that
came together and I was part of and that
it's interesting that you say that
because I mean what I knew of dolomite
was my aunts and uncles and mom like
listen to her and thinking I'm thinking
oh my god am I supposed to be hearing
this I didn't know his story behind it
and I certainly didn't expect to get it
from this film but instead of getting a
blaxploitation film what we got was a
film about perseverance entrepreneurship
about a self-made man who lived his
version of the American Dream I mean it
blew my mind yeah cuz it that that I
mean a movie came out during that the
blaxploitation era but the this movie is
about a guided maid that believed in
himself and you know paid move paid for
his movies out of his pocket and got his
records done it she did him in his
living room and he's a guy that had like
the least amount and his biggest gift
was that he believed in him stuff
because he wasn't a genius you know in
his movies a super crude no but he
believed in himself and that's a really
inspirational story does Eddie Murphy
have that much confidence in himself oh
yeah I've always been really confident
good yeah you bet like and every
cocktail it felt like with him he'd bet
on himself in every single situation
didn't matter what it was he's like nope
I Know Who I am I know what I can do I
know the audience
they're like is that you like you bet on
yourself in every single situation I'm
always confident even if we crash and
burn even I've mastered the art of
walking away from the trainwreck
confidently say were you in that plane
crash yeah he's a cultural icon which
one of your characters do you get the
most when that people come to ask you
about that characters movie the movie
that people the most is coming to
America I was gonna say yeah some reason
that movie worked its way into the
culture to where it's like you know
everybody has seen it and it's always on
television
lines from the movie and people dress up
like the characters on Halloween and
rath there's a restaurant that turns
itself into McDowell's on Halloween so
none no other movie like that one I in
my opinion it is the best comedy ever
made and a perfect comedy from Star Trek
we can argue though I'm not very it's a
perfect a perfect comedic film
perfection yeah so I'm a little nervous
because you're doing it you're gonna
look I wouldn't have done we wouldn't
have this 30 years ago we wouldn't have
done this sequel we wouldn't have done
this movie unless we had came up with a
clever way to connect the story and and
live up to you know whatever
expectations people have for it did you
always have an idea when you finished
we're prints I came would be or where
you wanted him to be after that no you
know we weren't three years we didn't
even think about doing a sequel to this
movie and I would hear we would talk
they would be talks about doing a play
you know like let's do it coming to
America play and that never came
together and then
right around the time I did the gut that
Mark Twain prize somebody came and
pitched you know the guy that directed
Black Panther Brian Cougar hear him and
the writer came and they pitched it was
like he got an idea for coming to
America and I didn't really like their
idea but it was like I was like this
dude this guy wasn't coming to America
maybe I should think about is like this
one a director okay so where does he
where do we find print sacking where do
we pick up he's he's in Africa so this
movie set more in Africa in America yeah
it's mostly mostly in Africa and Wesley
Wesley Snipes is in it and he's playing
an African warlord named general is he
he is really he's amazing in Dolomites
as well who knew he had I mean I knew
that I knew I've always you know I've
always known and I told him years ago
Wesley started out doing everything you
know and then he came on the scene right
when that big one when the action movies
which Schwarzenegger and Stallone they
used to be like these the the Marvel
movies now like the action movies used
to be the biggest and he jumped into
that world with Van Dam and Seagal a he
became all of that you know but and
that's what he had gotten really famous
for that's what people associate him
with but I've always known that Wesley
could do everything I've seen him do in
the beginning he did everything when you
feel like you've done everything like
you have was that the reason why you
said now's the time to go back to SNL
because you're like in a space where you
fight then I've done everything there's
the hours I'm having so much fun sitting
on the couch at home and just being you
know with it within earshot of the
children how I said you know a you know
so good I could sit on this couch and
not ever get off and I'm
I want that so but I was like I don't
want to have the last movie I did be mr.
Church you know what I love mr.
churchman and people know me for being
funny so I wanted to do some funny so
dolomite came together then coming to
America came together then Beverly Hills
Cop came together I was like okay this
is a great way to kind of book in my
thin case I never want to get off this
couch and except to just do stand-up I
could not be I could do that and I could
have like my little funny little book in
and while I was at it so let me go and
host Saturday Night Live so this nice
meet little book in you know it's nice
can you still do can you do like velvet
Jones now I want to be home like look
can you do those Jones yes you can you
could do you could be you could still be
funny without you know stepping on
people's toes and getting people ruffled
and all email you could stand like when
you step on toes in community step on
people's toes and maybe outside you have
to go apologize to stepping on other
people's toes
we're gonna get mr. Robinson we're gonna
get Gumby oh good yeah you get him I'm
sure they'll be mr. Robinson I'm sure
they'll be Gumby and I'm sure there'll
be a buckwheat all right I just want to
end on saying I love this film there's a
lot of buzz do you think about it do you
open your arms to it do you say I don't
want to think about it I just want to
think about how much I loved this movie
yeah well I'm uh I love it nobody ever
set off to make a bad movie everybody
wants to be in a good movie so when you
make a good movie and it's being well
received you love that now I never
listened to or read the stuff you know
because
you don't want to I don't read any of it
bad or good so um I'm just happy to be
involved in something that you know
people want to see
[Music]
[Applause]